Trascrizione: Manuela Sagliocco
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Era il novembre 2019
quando scrivevo queste parole,
preparando il TEDx,
che sarebbe stato a marzo 2020.
Le parole erano - iniziava così:
"Immaginate per un attimo" -
questa la proposta
che volevo fare al pubblico -
"immaginate per un attimo
se ci fosse impedito di avere
relazioni dal vivo con le persone,
e potessimo solo avere
relazioni digitali".
Quindi computer, device, telefonino".
E questo era l'inizio del mio TED.
Quando, due mesi fa,
ho ripreso in mano questo intervento,
in effetti vedendo questa frase
mi sono disorientata.
A parte che l'intervento
l'ho dovuto rifare completamente,
perché in realtà
tutto questo era accaduto!
Cioè, non era una simulazione.
Ero come una veggente, in qualche modo:
e stranamente, avevo chiesto alle persone
di poter immaginare questa cosa,
che allora era inimmaginabile
e che invece poi è accaduta.
E tutti siamo passati
attraverso questa esperienza
della connessione rarefatta.
E difatti abbiamo fatto l'esperienza
di cosa vuol dire sentirsi connessi -
o sentirsi meno connessi, socialmente.
Sentirsi connessi,
come dice il titolo di questo intervento,
ha il sapore del cioccolato,
nel senso che per il nostro cervello,
dal punto di vista fisiologico,
della sua fisiologia,
mangiare una tavoletta di cioccolato,
cioè un pezzettino di cioccolato,
produce lo stesso effetto
del sentirsi connessi,
dell'essere riconosciuti,
di avere in qualche modo
una gratificazione, del sentirsi visti.
E questo per noi ha:
un valore sicuramente emotivo;
un valore, in generale, sociale;
però è importante capire che ha,
per le aziende, un valore anche economico.
Ed è quello di cui mi sono accorta
facendo una serie di corsi
che hanno coinvolto 6-700 persone,
a cui ho fatto per un certo periodo,
nei corsi, due domande.
E a queste due domande -
che farò anche a voi, adesso -
ho chiesto di rispondere,
poi, su dei post-it.
Questi post-it li ho raccolti
in maniera un po' maniacale,
li ho messi da parte tutti,
non sapendo cosa farne;
e ne ho raccolti una montagna,
di questi post-it;
e poi, a un certo punto,
ho collegato un po' di cose.
Il tema su cui -
le domande ve le faccio,
e vi chiedo di avere
un minimo di concentrazione,
magari di provare a scrivere
su un post-it virtuale,
nella vostra testa,
la risposta a questa
domanda, semplicissima.
La prima è:
pensate a un momento
della vostra vita lavorativa,
anche recente,
in cui avete provato un'emozione di gioia,
di felicità.
Provate a riportarlo alla vostra mente;
e provate anche a riportare
alla vostra mente
che cosa l'aveva causata,
qual era il motivo di questa gioia.
Provate a collegare.
Qual'era il trigger, cosa l'ha innestata?
Fatelo perché poi vi interrogo,
quindi applicatevi.
Ecco: scrivetelo su questo post-it:
poi, in qualche modo, magari
la condivisione è più facile.
La seconda domanda, invece, era questa:
immaginate, trovate un momento
della vostra vita lavorativa
in cui avete avuto, invece,
un'emozione di rabbia oppure di tristezza.
Qui, in genere, si fa
meno fatica a trovarle.
Anche qui, provate a pescare quel momento.
Qualche secondo per pescarlo.
E adesso, che cosa l'ha provocato?
Qual è stato l'innesco,
il trigger di queste emozioni,
rabbia e tristezza;
e poi, anche,
che effetto hanno avuto
su di voi queste emozioni,
da una parte la gioia,
e dall'altra parte
la rabbia e la tristezza,
proprio nel vostro lavoro,
nel vostro modo di lavorare?
Come vi dicevo, ho raccolto
moltissimi post-it.
Questi che vedete riguardano
solo l'emozione della gioia:
vi voglio presentare
una spremuta di questi.
Qualcuno l'abbiamo trascritto,
però è proprio la sintesi
di quello che questi post-it raccontavano.
Gioia:
un complimento per il lavoro svolto;
ricevere feedback positivi;
quando viene apprezzata una mia idea;
una mail inaspettata -
si intende positiva, in questo caso -
dal proprio responsabile;
quando arriva l'email del capo
che dice: "Ben fatto! ";
ricevere i complimenti
a conclusione di un lavoro complesso.
Queste sono veramente alcune:
e, diciamo, l'80% di queste centinaia
di post-it che ho raccolto
erano di questo tipo,
cioè riconoscimento sociale,
quello che viene chiamato
il "Social Reward",
la ricompensa che passa
attraverso il fatto di sentirsi visti,
sentirsi connessi, sentirsi riconosciuti;
e la motivazione umana al lavoro
mi è sembrata, improvvisamente,
molto semplice:
qualcuno ha scritto,
ma veramente pochissimi,
"L'aumento di stipendio", "Le ferie", uno;
però è stata una cosa molto rara.
Non che questo non dia gioia:
però è un'altra cosa,
un altro tipo di gioia.
Questa è proprio, come dire,
qualcosa che sta alla base
della motivazione al lavoro.
E vediamo invece, al contrario,
alle altre due domande,
all'altra domanda: cosa hanno risposto?
Tristezza,
e rabbia:
allora, i due motivi principali
di tristezza e rabbia al lavoro
sono - questo veramente,
diciamo, nel 90% dei casi -
ingiustizie subite,
la sensazione di essere trattati
non equamente, con iniquità;
oppure il contrario di quella prima,
che è non sentirsi visti,
non sentirsi considerati,
le idee che non vengono
condivise eccetera.
Questa è la mappa
della motivazione umana al lavoro.
Ho voluto quindi approfondire questo tema,
perché sembrava veramente semplice:
ma così, come dire,
sorprendentemente diffuso
che era curioso [notare]
come tutti hanno
lo stesso tipo di emozioni
collegate alle stesse cose.
E allora,
approfondendo nel campo, appunto,
della motivazione nel nostro cervello,
che cosa accade con la motivazione,
ho scoperto che di fatto funziona così:
noi abbiamo un apparato che è il sistema
della ricompensa, della motivazione.
La motivazione, per noi,
è come una benzina del nostro cervello,
lo fa funzionare meglio.
È quella che ci tiene in piedi,
che ci fa anche impegnare,
fare sacrifici e tenere duro,
perché la motivazione è la spinta
a raggiungere qualcosa,
un motivo per fare qualcosa.
Ecco: nel nostro cervello,
abbiamo questo apparato
che è il "reward system",
il sistema della ricompensa,
dove i "social reward"
hanno veramente una parte fondamentale,
cioè il riconoscimento sociale
è la base, una delle basi
più importanti della motivazione.
E perché questo è importante
anche da un punto di vista economico?
È importante dal punto di vista economico
perché la dopamina, che ha l'effetto
di questo social reward,
di questo sistema di ricompensa,
questo neurotrasmettitore -
è un carburante essenziale
per il cervello pensante,
per quella parte del nostro cervello -
la corteccia prefrontale -
che è quella che ha
le funzioni cosiddette esecutive.
Quindi la capacità di essere
concentrati, attenti;
la creatività, la flessibilità
mentale, le performance.
Quindi, la motivazione che passa
attraverso il riconoscimento
sociale al lavoro,
cioè sentirsi dire "Ben fatto!"
attiva nel nostro cervello un meccanismo
che poi produce non solo benessere,
ma anche performance.
E questo, da un punto di vista economico,
direi che è del tutto produttivo.
Questo sistema garantisce
la nostra connessione:
noi vogliamo essere riconosciuti.
Però, contemporaneamente,
abbiamo anche un altro sistema
che è pure molto attivo
nel nostro cervello,
che è quello del "social pain",
cioè il dolore sociale.
Il meccanismo attraverso cui
noi avvertiamo dolore sociale
corre sugli stessi network
del dolore fisico:
quando noi proviamo dolore fisico -
ci cade qualcosa sull'alluce -
proviamo sicuramente un dolore fisico;
ma quando veniamo esclusi,
per esempio, dai gruppi,
quando veniamo esclusi dal lavoro,
quando veniamo esclusi, anche,
dalla vita sociale, normale, degli amici -
l'esclusione e l'ingiustizia
producono nel nostro cervello dolore.
Ed è un dolore che comunque, poi,
da un punto di vista,
anche qui mi vien da dire economico,
all'interno delle realtà aziendali
produce: rabbia; disinteresse; disimpegno;
aggressività passiva -
oltre che, di fatto,
la voglia di disimpegnarsi.
Quindi, da una parte quell'altra emozione
che porta le persone a impegnarsi di più
per ottenere dei risultati:
dall'altra parte, questo tipo di emozione,
questo tipo di effetti, di dolore sociale,
che come il dolore fisico
corre sugli stessi network,
che invece produce voglia
di cambiare lavoro,
voglia di andarsene, demotivazione,
voglia di scappare eccetera eccetera.
Però questo preserva
anche la nostra connessione,
cioè sono proprio due meccanismi
che ci fanno percepire
se siamo connessi
o se ci stiamo disconnettendo,
quindi garantiscono in qualche modo
la nostra connessione sociale.
Il nostro cervello sociale,
d'altra parte, è un cervello -
meraviglioso, mi vien da dire,
perché ha degli apparati
che sono capaci in qualche modo
di tenerci sempre sintonizzati
anche sul cervello sociale altrui.
Abbiamo nel nostro cervello sociale
quella parte che forse tutti conoscete:
i neuroni specchio, cioè l'empatia,
quindi quel meccanismo attraverso cui noi,
se vedessimo qualcuno
che cade dalle scale adesso
avremmo in qualche modo -
se si rompesse qualcosa
di serio, soprattutto -
una sorta di dolore
come se lo provassimo noi.
Le nostre emozioni sono contagiose
perché i nostri cervelli sono contagiati,
sono connessi al cervello
sociale degli altri.
Quindi, per qualcosa
che accade a un altro,
l'emozione la sento come se fosse mio.
Questa non è connessione,
questa è "connessione
meravigliosa", mi vien da dire.
Anche qui dentro, l'attenzione condivisa
che abbiamo sugli interventi -
su questo e su altri interventi -
questa attenzione condivisa
significa che i nostri cervelli,
in qualche modo,
stanno ondeggiano sulla stessa
lunghezza d'onda.
Ed è come se fossimo un po' un tutt'uno:
se potessero registrare
le nostre onde cerebrali, adesso,
attraverso alcuni apparati,
probabilmente ci accorgemmo
che siamo tutti sintonizzati,
siamo un tutt'uno;
e questa è una connessione
che è già esistente,
che non è visibile ma è sicuramente
qualcosa che possiamo percepire.
Sentirsi visti, sentirsi connessi,
sentirsi riconosciuti,
è qualcosa che ci serve per vivere,
quindi ne abbiamo bisogno veramente tutti;
però è importante anche la reciprocità.
Così come noi abbiamo bisogno,
[bisogna] essere capaci
di essere per gli altri,
in qualche modo di riconoscere gli altri,
di vederli, di farli sentire presenti,
soprattutto quando parliamo
anche di lavoro.
E questo, come dire,
è qualcosa di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Quindi il monito
di questo mio intervento -
anche di questa giornata,
mi vien da dire - è:
ricordiamoci che voi
siete il cioccolato per me,
ma anche voi siete
il cioccolato per gli altri.
E quindi, forza.
(Applausi)